éduquer et instruire forme est soignée
accompagnés sont des missions
essentielles
nous continuerons de faire de l'école de
l'apprentissage et de la formation tout
au long de la vie le socle de notre
société nous entamerons la
revalorisation et la transformation des
carrières des enseignants des
professeurs des soignants nous mènerons
une politique ambitieuse pour l'hôpital
auquel je tiens t'en es pour une
médecine plus humaine
centrée sur le patient nous aurons aussi
cette année à prendre des décisions
essentielles pour nos concitoyens en
situation de handicap comme pour nos
aînés en situation de dépendance 2020
sera aussi l'année où un nouveau modèle
écologique doit se déployer nombre de
décisions ont été prises en la matière
fermer les centrales à charbon
arrêtez les nouveaux forages et je ne
citerai pas tous ici j'attends beaucoup
des propositions que prépare 150 de nos
compatriotes qui se sont engagés dans la
convention citoyenne et travaille depuis
plusieurs semaines d'arrache-pied il
nous reviendra au printemps prochain
d'affirmer des choix nouveaux efforts
une stratégie sur plusieurs années pour
réduire nos émissions de gaz à effet de
serre et ainsi lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique mais aussi pour
oeuvrer en faveur de la biodiversité
cette stratégie nationale doit être
écologique et économique
c'est à dire que nous devons préserver
la planète en créant et nouveaux emplois
elle doit être écologique et sociale
nous devons changer nos habitudes en
aidant les plus modestes à se déplacer
se loger en dépensant moins et en
émettant moins elle doit être écologique
et culturel cela doit être une politique
nouvelle d'aménagement de nos paysages
de redécouverte du bo de réinvention
d'une qualité de vie à la française